.
Es war einmal ein Mann,
den alle Firabig-Kari nannten.
* Schnattern *
Dieser Mann wanderte in die Karibik
aus, wo er all sein Geld verlor.
Im Nachhinein weiss ich,
dass ich leichtgläubig war.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Aber ja, nun ist es zu spät.
Dafür fand Firabig-Kari
dort die Liebe.
Und er hatte vier Söhne,
die alle irgendwann den
umgekehrten Weg des Vaters machten:
von der Dominikanischen Republik
in die Schweiz.
* Volkstümliche Musik *
Ist das Land so, wie du es
dir vorgestellt hast?
Nein, es ist nicht so,
Es ist ganz anders.
In diesem Drama geht es
um Werden und Vergehen.
Um Träumen und Scheitern.
Um Flüchten und Standhalten.
Träume bleiben Träume,
sie bleiben auf der Seite.
Am Ende macht man etwas anderes.
Das ist die unendliche Geschichte
einer Familie
und ihrer Suche nach dem Glück -
irgendwo zwischen hier und dort.
Fertig, los.
* Lachen *
# I bi der Schacher Seppeli,
# im ganze Land bekannt.
# Bi früehner
s flöttischt Bürschtli gsi,
# jetzt bin i e Vagant.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Melancholische Klaviermelodie:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Carlos Feierabend hat 17 Jahre lang -
also die Hälfte seines Lebens -
am Vierwaldstättersee,
sozusagen im Herzen der Urschweiz,
gelebt, geliebt und gearbeitet.
Ich habe es gut hier,
ich habe es nicht schlecht.
Aber ich  ...
Ich bin nicht ganz zufrieden.
Ich suche mein Glück
in der Dominikanischen Republik.
Mit 17 Jahren ist Carlos
im Kanton Uri angekommen -
voller Träume und Hoffnungen.
Jetzt, mit 34,
scheint die Schwerkraft des Lebens
den Schweizer aus der Karibik
ein wenig ausgenüchtert zu haben.
Carlos und all seine Brüder wohnen
heute in der Heimat ihres Vaters.
Sie haben hier Arbeit und Freunde
gefunden.
Soll ich noch waschen?
Wenn du möchtest.
Und ja, auch Liebe.
In diesem Fall zu Samira Ragotti, 27,
derzeit arbeitslos.
Und trotzdem fehlt etwas.
Seit fünf Jahren
denke ich darüber nach,
ob ich zurückgehen soll oder nicht.
Fünf Jahre, fast sechs Jahre.
Nach fast sechs Jahren habe ich
entschieden, dass ich zurückgehe.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ein paar Jahre bevor er Samira traf,
schien sein Glück
bereits perfekt zu sein:
Er wurde Vater.
Ich sehe mein Kind
eigentlich sehr, sehr selten.
Und ...
Mein Verhältnis zur Mutter
meines Sohnes ist nicht so gut.
Es gibt, wie bei jeder Ehe,
die auseinanderbricht ...
Einige haben mehr Krach,
andere nicht.
Jetzt sind es fünf Jahre,
seit wir etwas ...
Seit fünf Jahren
verstehen wir uns nicht gut.
Das ist ...
Also ich bin
immer noch glücklich, ...
... aber ich bin auch traurig.
Es hatte so schön angefangen.
2014 im Kantonsspital Uri.
Es fühlt sich immer noch
wie ein Traum an.
Seit ...
Als ich das erste Mal herkam,
hatte sie solche Schmerzen.
Und, ja ...
Ich habe es noch nicht richtig
erfasst, aber es ist schön.
Komm, nimm meine Fingerchen.
(Flüsternd) Jetzt schläft er wieder.
Schon bald nach diesen Aufnahmen
trennte sich das Paar -
und seither ist es,
kurz gesagt, schwierig.
Viel Licht im Gesicht, ich weiss.
Ich weiss, dass er in der Nähe ist
und ich kann ihn nicht sehen.
Das schmerzt noch mehr.
Wenn ich weit weg bin,
kann ich mich daran gewöhnen.
Ich weiss, dass mein Sohn
mich später suchen wird.
Aber im Moment ...
Ich finde ...
Ich habe hier keinen Platz mehr.
Ich möchte zurück
nach Rancho Arriba.
Das habe ich letztes Mal
auch mitgenommen.
Jetzt will Carlos also auswandern.
Und Samira, seine neue Liebe,
möchte ihn nach Rancho Arriba,
dorthin, wo er aufgewachsen ist,
begleiten.
Mein Herz schlägt für ihn.
Deshalb gibt es für mich im Moment
diesen Weg mit ihm.
Das ist nun halt in Rancho Arriba.
... ein Grosser
oder sind es alles kleine?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Carlos packt alles,
was ihm wichtig ist, zusammen.
Seine Zeit in der Schweiz
geht zu Ende.
Er will in der Karibik
ganz neu anfangen:
auf der Farm seines Vaters.
So, wie ich meinen Vater kannte ...
Wenn ich erzählen würde
oder wenn er wüsste,
was ich hier erlebe ...
Besser gesagt,
meine ganze Situation.
Er würde sagen: "Es ist gut,
komm wieder zurück."
Zurück in die Berge
der Dominikanischen Republik.
* Lockere Musik *
Hierher zog es in den 80er-Jahren
einige Schweizer Auswanderer.
Sie zogen in ein kleines Kaff namens
Rancho Arriba, in eine Landschaft,
die manchmal ein bisschen
an die Schweiz erinnert.
* Lockere Musik *
* Schnattern *
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Dort traf ich Karl Feierabend
zum ersten Mal.
* Fröhliche Ländlermusik *
Carlos heisst er hier, früher Kari,
kommt aus Rotkreuz.
Karl Feierabend, der in seinem ersten
Leben für alle der Firabig-Kari war.
17 Jahre lang war er Schnapsbrenner
mit eigener Brennerei -
gern gesehen auf allen Höfen.
*  Ländlermusik, Chlefelen *
Dann, 1982,
begann er sein zweites Leben.
Kari packte Hab und Gut
in einen Container
und verschickte ihn hierher
in die Tropen.
* Ländlermusik, Chlefelen *
Farmer wollte er werden, Grossfarmer.
Dass er hier nur ein paar Gänse
statt einer Rinderherde
vor sich hertreiben würde,
hat er sich damals, zu Hause
in Rotkreuz, nicht träumen lassen.
17 Jahre lang hatte er gespart:
über 200'000 Fr., immerhin -
als Startkapital in der Fremde.
* Aufgeregtes Schnattern *
Eigentlich wollte ich nicht hierhin,
sondern nach Australien.
Aber dort bekam ich kein Visum.
Und dann ...
Es kam einer von der **Investkonsu
zu mir und sagte, ...
... in der Dominikanischen Republik
könne man auch Farmen kaufen.
Und so hatte es begonnen.
Kari schloss sich einer Gruppe
Landinteressenten an
und flog auf die Karibikinsel.
Auf Vermittlung der schweizer-
dominikanischen Maklergruppe INI
besichtigte Kari einige Farmen
und entschloss sich schliesslich
zusammen mit Fischli Hans
aus dem Toggenburg
zum Kauf einer Farm von 93 ha.
66 davon gehörten Kari.
In einem achttägigen Besuchsprogramm
schleuste man sie durchs Land.
Für nur 50 Rp. pro Tag
könne man hier Taglöhner anstellen,
wurde versprochen.
Bereits am achten Tag hiess es:
Vertragsabschlüsse in unseren Büros,
nachmittags frei.
Die Gruppo INI versprach, bei der
Bewirtschaftung behilflich zu sein
und schloss mit Kari
einen Vertrag ab.
Die Makler
kauften Dünger und Saatgut,
versprachen, die Ernte zu verkaufen
und rechneten die schönen Gewinne
aus, die da zu machen seien.
Die Bohnen wuchsen zwar,
doch aus den Gewinnen wurde nichts.
Kari war auf falsche Berechnungen
hereingefallen.
Waren Sie zu leichtgläubig?
Im Nachhinein weiss ich,
dass ich leichtgläubig war.
Aber ja, nun ist es zu spät.
Nach anderthalb Jahren war er pleite.
Kari verlor sein ganzes Land,
für das er über 200'000 Fr.
hingeblättert hatte.
Ein Lebenstraum in Trümmern.
Wieso kehrten Sie nicht
in die Schweiz zurück?
Weil ich in der Schweiz
nichts mehr hatte.
Alles, was ich hatte, habe ich
mit dem Container hierhergebracht.
Kari!
Ven acá, mi amor!
Pero por dios!
Im Laufe der Zeit sind
noch weitere Gründe dazugekommen.
Einer heisst Marina.
Und einer Carlos.
Mhm.
Aus dem Baby von damals
ist ein Mann geworden -
einer, der vor sieben Jahren
selbst Vater wurde.
Das hat mein Sohn für mich gemalt.
Ein Vulkan, ganz schön.
Das nehme ich mit.
Ein richtiger Künstler,
wie der Vater.
Er sagt, es sei schade,
dass ich so weit weggehe.
V.a. kann er kann mich
nicht besuchen -
wenn er das möchte.
Aber wir haben abgemacht,
dass er mich eines Tages
in der Karibik besuchen wird.
Zusammen mit der Mutter.
Schon morgen fliegen sie zusammen
in die Dominikanische Republik.
Ich bin ziemlich nervös.
Seit zwei, drei Tagen schwirrt mir
nichts anderes im Kopf herum:
Was müssen wir noch alles tun?
Sind wir bereit?
Haben wir alles?
Es ist schon nicht so einfach,
aber ich freue mich mega.
Aber ja, es rückt immer näher.
Die ganze Reise
macht einen schon nervös.
Carlos wandert definitiv aus.
Samira will sich auf dieser Reise
klar darüber werden,
ob sie sich ein Leben in der Karibik
vorstellen kann.
Was denkst du?
Ich sage 23.
- Ich hoffe, dass es 23 sind.
Sonst müssen wir wieder auspacken.
Genau 23.
- Perfekt.
Genau, es stimmt.
Ui, ich habe verschwitzte Hände.
So, der ist fertig.
Ein Gepäck weniger.
- Geschafft.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Carlos ist in seiner Zeit
in der Schweiz
zum begeisterten
Schrebergärtner geworden.
Seine paar Quadratmeter Land
ausserhalb von Flüelen
halfen ihm in den vergangenen Jahren
über manch dunkle Stunden hinweg.
Das ist wie ...
Das ist mein Rancho Arribo
in der Schweiz.
Mit der Hütte.
Wir haben uns immer hier getroffen,
etwas grilliert.
Ein Bier getrunken.
Das war für uns,
für mich und meine Brüder,
sehr schön.
Seit Samira mit mir zusammen ist
ohnehin.- Ja.
Heute ist der letzte Tag im Garten.
Ja, es ist ...
Es ist irgendwie traurig,
aber so ist das Leben.
An seinem letzten Abend in der
Schweiz hat Carlos seine Brüder,
Verwandte und Freunde
zu einem Abschiedsfest eingeladen.
Sepp, hoi.
Gut?
- Ja.
Hoi, Samira.
- Hoi.
Onkel Sepp und Tante Lisbeth
sind gekommen.
Hallo, Mami.
Und Samiras Mutter Angela,
die sich nur schwer
mit dem Gedanken anfreunden kann,
dass ihre Tochter
vielleicht auswandert.
In dem Moment, als ich das erfuhr,
brach schon mal eine Welt zusammen.
Ich verlor den Boden
unter den Füssen.
Ich war nicht dafür,
dass sie sofort auswandert.
Es hat sich nun alles
mit den Gesprächen ergeben.
Sie geht jetzt mal schauen.
Im Inneren hofft man natürlich,
dass beide wieder zurückkommen.
Carlos Entscheidung, die Schweiz zu
verlassen, macht den einen Sorgen.
Andere scheinen ihn fast ein wenig
um seinen Mut zu beneiden.
So etwa Sämi,
der Jüngste der Feierabend-Brüder.
Doch, ich möchte
schon einmal zurück.
Ich weiss nicht wann,
aber irgendwann einmal.
Was vermisst du am meisten?
Am meisten? Das Land des Vaters.
Die Pferde, die Kühe -
all die Sachen.
Ja.
- Genau.
Und auch die Früchte.
Pepe, den Zweitgeborenen,
der hier auch einen Schrebergarten
gemietet hat,
plagen indes
keine Auswanderungsgelüste.
Momentan nicht, nein.
Ich habe
so viele Weiterbildungen gemacht.
Und meine Frau
würde sicher nicht mitkommen.
Das ist der grösste Teil.
Ich habe seit zwei Monaten ein Kind.
Das Kind soll hier aufwachsen
und eine richtige Ausbildung machen.
* Lüpfige Ländlermusik *
Nach fast 40 Jahren wiederholt sich
die Geschichte der Feierabends
in gewisser Weise:
Wie einst Kari bricht nun wieder ein
Feierabend in Richtung Tropen auf.
Bei ihm kommt es
weniger tragisch aus.
Er investiert nicht dieses Geld.
Er kann dort ohnehin überleben.
Sie haben ...
Sie können gratis wohnen.
Von daher ist es kein Problem.
Bananen und Kaffee gibt es immer.
Das reicht schnell einmal.
* Gemütliche Ländlermusik,
Stimmengewirr *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Am nächste Morgen
am Flughafen Zürich.
Nun müssen sie Abschied nehmen.
Vom Patenkind ...
... von der Schwiegermutter ...
... von den Brüdern ...
... und von den Schwestern.
* Schniefen *
Alles Gute und pass auf dich auf.
Trag Sorge. Ich habe dich fest lieb.
(Samira) Ich dich auch.
Du kannst immer anrufen.
- (Samira) Ja, danke.
Ich fühle mich nicht einmal nervös.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
in die Ferien zu gehen.
Ich realisiere es noch nicht.
Mal sehen ...
Mami ...
(Angela) Alles, alles Gute.
* Unverständliche Worte *
Tschüss.
Es ist schon hart,
sich zu verabschieden,
auch wenn ich wieder retourkomme.
Es ist doch eine längere Zeit und
man weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Ich freue mich,
mit ihm diese Reise zu machen
und dass wir es geniessen können.
* Sentimentale Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Gut 15 Jahre nach seiner Auswanderung
haben wir Firabig-Kari
ein zweites Mal besucht.
Es stellte sich die Frage:
Warum kehrt einer wie er, pleite wie
er war, nicht in die Schweiz zurück,
unter das Dach des Sozialstaates?
Es war nicht schwierig, ihn
wieder zu finden in Rancho Arriba,
dem kleinen Dorf im Kaffeegebiet.
Wo er genau lebt,
sieht man von Weitem.
* Lockere Musik *
Diese Fahne
bekam ich von Meier Walti,
einem pensionierten Pöstler.
Er ist ein alter Motorradfreund.
Wir gingen oft zusammen schiessen.
Hast du manchmal Heimweh
nach der Schweiz?
Nein, Heimweh habe ich nicht,
aber ich denke immer wieder
an die schönen Zeiten.
Trotz Pleite und Pech
ist Kari dageblieben.
Und auf Anhieb
käme keiner auf die Idee,
dass es sich hier
um einen Ausländer handelt.
Kari lebt
wie ein einheimischer Campesino -
einer mit Schweizerfahne allerdings.
Kari hat sich mit ein paar 1'000 Fr.,
die ihm nach seiner Pleite
von damals übriggeblieben waren,
3 ha Land in der gleichen Gegend
gekauft.
Hier lebt er seit elf Jahren
als Kleinbauer.
Und irgendwie wundert er sich
noch heute darüber,
wie er hierher geraten ist.
Sie haben mich überredet.
Ich wusste nicht einmal,
wo die Dominikanische Republik ist.
Ich hörte nur etwas
von Santo Domingo.
Ich wusste nicht, dass Santo Domingo
in der Dominikanischen Republik ist.
Was wusstest du denn
von Santo Domingo?
Eigentlich nichts,
es gab nur ein Lied.
# Und am Abend träumten sie
# von Santo Domingo.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, wer es sang.
* Schlager: "Santo Domingo"
von Die Flippers *
# Und am Abend träumen sie
von Santo Domingo.
# Von Santo Domingo
und weissen Orchideen.
Ab und zu zieht es Kari zurück
auf jene grosse, schöne Farm,
die ihm einmal gehört hatte -
und die er nach nur anderthalb Jahren
verloren hatte,
weil ihm das Geld ausgegangen war.
# Und Wundern
die dort noch gescheh'n
Fühlst du dich hintergangen?
Sicher.
# Am Abend träumen sie
von Santo Domingo.
Schöne Pferde.
# ... von Santo Domingo.
226'000 Fr.,
Karis ganze Ersparnisse,
sind hier verlocht.
Nach Karis Pleite
konnte der Vorbesitzer
das Land
ein zweites Mal verkaufen.
Aber Kari, der am Anfang
praktisch kein Spanisch sprach,
kriegte das alles auch
erst nach und nach mit.
* Lüpfige Ländlermusik, Chlefelen *
Inzwischen hat er vier Söhne:
Kari, Freddy, Sämi und Seppe-Toni.
Vier Schweizer Buben -
arm, aber zufrieden.
So viel Gotthelf
gibt es nur noch in der Karibik.
* Kari hustet. *
Grosses Glück
in einer bescheidenen Hütte.
Alles selber gebaut von Kari:
zwei Zimmer und eine Küche.
* Kinderstimmen im Hintergrund *
Hier schläft niemand
ohne Moskitonetz.
Die Scheissmücken,
die einem um den Kopf surren.
Im Schlafzimmer
wachen nebst hiesigen Heiligen
auch Schweizer Ikonen
über die helvetisch-karibische Ehe.
Wir gehen zum Pferd.
Da hat es einen Mandarinenbaum.
Das ist das Scheisshaus -
System "platsch".
Da ein Orangenbaum.
Auf 3 ha, die einmal Wiese waren,
ist eine veritable Plantage
entstanden.
Mit zwölf Sorten Bananen,
Orangen, Mandarinen,
Passionsfrüchten, Kiwis und Kaffee.
Wir haben ...
... roten Kaffee.
Und wir haben gelben Kaffee.
Der wird nie rot.
Der ist so reif.
Der heisst Catuai.
* Spanische Wortfetzen *
Sie klettern wie Affen
auf die Bäume.
**
Damals hatten wir nur eine Wiese.
Jetzt haben wir
viele Früchte und Bäume.
Bist du stolz darauf,
was du erreicht hast? - Klar.
Bist du glücklich?
- (Zögernd) Ja.
Eben, gehen wir weiter.
Ja, gut.
# Am Abend träumen sie
# von Santo Domingo.
# Von Santo Domingo
# und weissen Orchideen.
# Von dem Märchen ...
Kaffee ist ein unsicheres Geschäft.
Kari lebt mehr schlecht als recht
von seinem kleinen Anwesen.
Am Kaffee verdient er, wenn's hoch
kommt, 1'000-2'000 Fr. pro Jahr.
Überlebt hat Kari,
weil er seine Schweissanlage
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht hatte.
Er flickt alles,
was ihm die Nachbarn bringen.
So kommt er auf ein Monatseinkommen
von umgerechnet 250-300 Fr.
Er ist so ein fleissiger Mensch.
Und er kümmert sich um die Kinder.
Er ist immer hier.
Er ist sehr häuslich.
Er geht nie aus. Er trinkt nicht.
Und er lungert nicht
auf der Strasse rum.
Ein guter Mann.
Nur ehrlich: Dieser riesige Bart.
Er schneidet ihn nie ab.
Nein, dieser Bart.
Das gefällt mir nicht an ihm.
Ehrlich: zu viel ...
... zu viel Haare im Gesicht.
Was gefällt dir hier?
- V.a. das Klima.
Und was stört dich hier?
Die Schelmen.
Warum? Wird viel gestohlen?
- Ja, leider.
Ist dir mal etwas zugestossen?
- Sie haben ...
Sie haben mich überfallen.
Sie haben Geld gestohlen.
Und mit der Farm
haben sie mich betrogen.
Ich habe eigentlich nur immer
verloren, nur immer verloren.
Du scheinst
aber nicht unglücklich.
Nein, das nicht.
(Radio) Die Schweiz beteiligt sich
an der dritten Konferenz,
die in den nächsten beiden Wochen im
brasilianischen Recife stattfindet.
Aus dem Innerschweizer Schnapsbrenner
ist ein karibischer Campesino
geworden.
Der einzige allerdings,
der Schweizer Radio International
hörte, so lange es dieses noch gab.
# ... Santo Domingo
# und weissen Orchideen.
# Von dem Märchen einer Nacht
# in Santo Domingo.
# Und Wundern,
# die dort noch geschehen.
Heute ist von Karis bescheidenem Heim
in den Bergen
der Dominikanischen Republik
nur noch eine Ruine übrig.
Eine Ruine voller Erinnerungen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Das waren zwei Becken.
Darin wusch mein Vater den Kaffee.
Jetzt haben wir
nicht so viel Kaffee.
Ich dachte, wir nehmen das weg.
Wir machen den Boden neu.
Und nachher machen wir
so was Ähnliches wie ein Dach.
Darum haben wir das
zusammengeschlagen.
Karis kleine Farm
ist völlig heruntergekommen.
Ehrlich gesagt, sie gleicht
inzwischen einer Müllhalde.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Bevor daran zu denken ist,
sich hier wohnlich einzurichten,
müssen Carlos und seine Partnerin
Samira zuerst einmal versuchen,
ein wenig Ordnung
ins Chaos zu bringen.
Carlos log nie,
wie es hier aussieht.
Er sagte immer,
es könnte wirklich schlimm aussehen.
Und, ja, so ist es nun halt leider.
Wir müssen nun halt etwas Zeit
und Arbeit investieren.
Aber wenn wir immer
etwas dranbleiben,
dann wird es gut.
**
Für Carlos ist es ein
Nachhausekommen in Rancho Arriba.
Für Samira ein Kulturschock.
Alle paar Minuten
ein Spontanbesucher,
der auf einen Schwatz vorbeikommt.
**
Ich muss schon sagen,
ich komme mir oft etwas -
wie soll ich es sagen? -
blöd vor, weil man
einfach nur daneben steht.
Man möchte auch mit ihnen reden,
aber ...
Es geht einfach nicht,
man versteht nichts.
Es macht einen auch müde.
Man hört es immer,
man strengt sich an,
um irgendetwas zu verstehen.
Aber ...
Es klappt noch nicht so recht.
Das macht einen etwas müde.
Sie muss durchhalten.
Es ist nicht so einfach,
ich verstehe sie schon.
Die Leute reden ziemlich viel.
Wir sind tagsüber hier und es
kommen sicher 20 Leute vorbei.
Einer fängt an zu reden,
sitzt eine halbe Stunde da.
Ich glaube, dass es für sie
nicht so einfach ist.
Ich hoffe ...
Mal sehen, wie es kommt.
Die kleine Farm der Feierabends
liegt ein bisschen
ausserhalb von Rancho Arriba,
einem verschlafenen kleinen Kaff,
gut zwei Autostunden
von Santo Domingo entfernt,
also ziemlich weit weg vom Schuss.
Besucher aus Europa verirren sich
kaum je hierher.
* Sanfte Musik, Strassenlärm *
Bis die Farm bewohnbar ist,
haben sich Carlos und Samira bei
Marina, Carlos Mutter, einquartiert.
Sie lebt hier mit ihrem Partner
Manolo und freut sich, ihren Sohn,
der sein halbes Leben in der Schweiz
war, wieder bei sich zu haben.
Ich bin überglücklich.
Ich habe mir immer gedacht,
dass einer meiner Söhne
zurückkommen könnte.
Ich wollte ein Haus wie dieses.
Aber die Finca haben wir behalten
für den Fall,
dass einer zurückkommt.
Marina umsorgt das junge Paar. Und
sie haben ein Dach über dem Kopf.
Privatsphäre gibt es hier
allerdings kaum.
**
Alles gut.
Todo bien.
Ich esse mit Löffel - wie immer.
Ich fühle mich wohl.
Ich habe meine Mutter in der Nähe.
Ich kann froh sein,
kann ich hier schlafen,
bis auf der Farm alles fertig ist.
Es gibt Dinge, die mir nicht ge-
fallen, die ich nicht bequem finde.
Es sind kleine Dinge.
Es geht schon, es ist in Ordnung so.
Ich muss sagen,
dass es für mich nicht so ...
Es ist ... klar ...
Ich muss mich umgewöhnen.
Aber ich wurde
sehr herzlich empfangen -
von der Mutter
und auch von ihrem Freund.
Auch von den Verwandten,
die ich schon getroffen habe.
Es sind wirklich alle ganz lieb.
Ich mag auch sein Mami schon sehr.
Ich bin auch dankbar,
dass ich hier sein darf.
Sie haben uns ein Zimmer
bereitgemacht.
Sie sind wirklich sehr herzlich.
Buen apetito.
Sie war nie mit uns am Tisch.
* Sie rufen sich gegenseitig
"Buon apetito" zu.
**
Sie will, dass du dableibst.
Sie möchte das Beste machen,
damit du bleibst.
**
Sie meint, ich müsse dich
schon gut behandeln,
sonst bekomme ich eine **
* Marina lacht. *
Siehst du, der muss immer beissen.
Immer beissen.
- Immer beissen.
Ich bin froh,
dass Samira bei mir ist.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass es ihr gut geht.
Schlimmer wäre,
wenn sie unglücklich wäre.
Ich denke, es geht ihr gut.
Oder, Schatzi?
Geht es dir gut?
- Mir geht es gut.
Schön.
Mit den beiden Süssen sowieso.
Mhm.
* Lockere Musik *
Schatzi?
- Hm?
Magst du Kokosnüsse?
- Ja.
Carlos möchte Samira ein Leben
in der Dominikanischen Republik
schmackhaft machen.
U.a. mit den exotischen Früchten,
die hier vor der Haustüre wachsen.
Danke.
Bitte.
Schön kühl?
- Mhm.
Sehr lecker.
- Ja.
Die Orangen müssen wir
alle zurückschneiden.
Die wurden nie zurückgeschnitten.
Die sind einfach nur gewachsen.
Es gibt noch viel Arbeit,
die wir hier machen müssen.
Schatzi, das sind Sternfrüchte.
Hat es welche?
- Ja, dort. - Oh, ja.
Aus der Ruine des Hauses,
in dem Carlos aufgewachsen ist,
möchten die beiden ein Heim machen
für ihre gemeinsame Zukunft.
Das nehmen wir weg.
Das schlagen wir weg.
Das gibt den ... Wie nennt man das?
Den Flur.
- Genau, das gibt den Flur.
Das gibt einen schön breiten Flur.
Da gibt es die Toilette.
Ein kleines Bad.
Das waren schon eure Zimmer, oder?
Ja.
Da werde ich ... Ich erhöhe
das Ganze um drei Steinreihen.
Dann kommt der Boden.
In jeder Ecke stand ein Bett.
Wir hatten also ein Zimmer
für vier Personen.
Das ging eigentlich gut.
Erinnerungen an eine Zeit,
in der die Feierabend-Buben
noch ihre Zukunft träumten.
Du musst aufpassen.
- Ja.
Ich wollte eigentlich
Erfinder werden.
Erfinder.
Es hat mir immer gefallen.
In der Schule
war ich nie richtig gut.
Ich habe immer Experimente
in der Werkstatt des Vaters gemacht.
Träume sind Träume - die bleiben
immer etwas auf der Seite.
Am Ende macht man etwas anderes.
Hier sind Carlos und seine Brüder
zur Schule gegangen,
ohne danach
wirkliche Perspektiven zu haben.
Die Arbeitslosigkeit
beträgt mehr als 50 %.
Und jeder, der hier noch bei Trost
ist, sagt sich: "Nichts wie weg!"
In ein anderes Land: in die USA, nach
Spanien oder eben in die Schweiz.
Carlito, der älteste Sohn von Kari,
wird hier von allen beneidet:
Er hat einen Schweizer Pass,
er kann gehen.
Und so kam es denn,
dass am 4. August 2005,
Carlito Feierabend
in der Schweiz eintraf.
Erwartet von seiner Tante Lisbeth
und ihrem Mann.
Hallo, Carlito. Hoi.
Deutsch kann Carlito fast gar nicht.
Mit seinem Vater
hat er immer Spanisch geredet.
Erste Verständigungsversuche.
Bien...
- Bienvenido.
Bienvenido.
Herzlich willkommen.
Willkommen.
- Willkommen.
So macht der Sohn des Kari
den umgekehrten Weg seines Vaters.
Er will hier arbeiten
und Geld verdienen,
das er seinem Vater
in die Karibik schicken kann.
Und er will in der Schweiz
das werden,
was bisher nur sein Pass
verspricht: ein richtiger Schweizer.
* Lüpfige Ländlermusik *
Du kannst rechts abbiegen.
Ein weiteres Jahr
ist ins Land gegangen.
Auf dem Weg ins richtige Schweizertum
ist Carlito gerade dabei,
auch den Schweizerischen
Führerausweis zu erwerben.
Fahrstunden gibt ihm Onkel Sepp.
Carlito wohnt jetzt in Flüelen -
im Herzen der Urschweiz sozusagen.
Er lebt bei seiner Tante Lisbeth,
der Schwester seines Vaters,
und ihrem Mann Sepp.
Und man mag ihn offensichtlich.
Hallo.
Gehen wir rein?
- Ja, sicher.
Fand er schnell ein Zuhause?
Er hat sich rasch eingewöhnt -
auch an den Luxus.
An den Luxus?
- Ja. Ich denke schon.
Was heisst das?
Er kauft sich gern etwas.
Müssen Sie ihn etwas zurückhalten?
- Ja, eher.
Aber er ist ordentlich und sauber.
Es hatten alle Angst,
er käme rein und würde alles
auf den Boden werfen.
Wie sie halt so sind, oder.
Man meint es zumindest.
Aber, ja ...
Es war nicht so. Er ist sauber.
Man kann ihn brauchen,
den sauberen Carlito.
Ein braver Schweizer Junge,
der seinen Verwandten
sogar den Kaffee bringt.
Das ist dein Zimmer?
- Das ist mein Zimmer, ja.
Aha. Und wie lebst du hier?
Gut, ruhig, allein.
Bist du ein bisschen allein?
Manchmal schon.
Ist es schwierig,
in der Schweiz Freunde zu finden?
Also für mich ist es
schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Warum?
Uh, da habe ich keine Ahnung.
Viele akzeptieren mich nicht.
Ja, ich finde schon ...
Warum denkst du,
akzeptieren sie dich nicht?
Oh, das weiss ich nicht.
Das kann ich nicht erklären.
Aha.
Aber es gefällt dir hier?
Ja, schon. Es gefällt mir genug.
Was gefällt dir in der Schweiz?
Also ...
Die Frauen.
Aha.
- Ja.
Kennst du viele Frauen?
Nicht viel, wenig.
Weil er ein bisschen einsam ist,
hat er sich zwei vierbeinige Freunde
angeschafft: Nino und Nano.
Einen Hund kann ich nicht haben,
also kaufte ich eine Ratte.
Zuerst wollte ich einen Affen,
aber den müsste man
in Afrika kaufen.
Dann hatte ich die Idee, eine Ratte
zu kaufen. Sie gefällt mir.
Was war der Grund, weshalb du
in die Schweiz kommen wolltest?
Also ...
Ich wollte meinem Vater helfen.
Deinem Vater helfen?
- Ja, meiner Familie.
Geld verdienen
und deinem Vater helfen?- Ja.
Geht das?
Ja, bis jetzt war es nicht so.
Vielleicht kommt es noch.
Wie willst du ihm helfen?
Geld schicken oder Land kaufen?
Ich wollte ...
Ich wollte ihm das geben,
was er immer wollte.
Eine Hacienda?
Er hat schon eine.
Ich wollte ein Haus für die Familie.
Meine Brüder wollten
an die Universität gehen.
Und ich wollte für alles bezahlen.
Dass das viele Geld,
das er verdienen möchte,
in der Schweiz
nicht auf der Strasse liegt,
musste Carlito schnell lernen.
Jetzt arbeitet er
für 20 Fr. pro Stunde
in der Fensterfabrik Püntener
in Erstfeld,
wo man grundsätzlich
voll des Lobes ist über ihn.
Er macht hier die Erfahrungen
eines ganz gewöhnlichen Immigranten:
einfache Arbeit,
statt plötzlicher Reichtum.
Und er hat ein Dilemma:
Er ist zwar
ein Schweizer mit Pass,
aber irgendwie halten ihn alle
für irgendetwas anderes.
Ist das hier anders
als in der Karibik?
Ja, schon.
- Was ist der Unterschied?
Hier muss man alles perfekt machen.
Aha.
- Das ist in Santo Domingo nicht so.
Carlito ist in eine Schweiz geraten,
von der er keine Ahnung hatte.
In eine moderne,
durchorganisierte Gesellschaft -
weit und breit
kein Pferdefuhrwerk.
Ist das Land so,
wie du es dir vorgestellt hast?
Nein, es ist nicht so.
Es ist ganz anders.
Wie hast du es dir vorgestellt?
Es ist ein Land,
wie es mein Vater immer beschrieb.
Es ist ein Land mit Kühen,
vielen Bauern usw.
Aber es ist schon anders.
Warst du traurig oder enttäuscht?
Nein, nein.
Manchmal finde ich es besser so.
Denkst du,
dass deine Zukunft hier ist?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Meine Zukunft ist hier.
Was ist dein grösster Wunsch?
Eine gute Arbeit, ein guter Lohn.
Ein schönes Haus, das ich
mit meiner Familie haben kann.
Eine Freundin, viele Kollegen.
Ein wesentlicher Schritt in der Ver-
schweizerung des Schweizers Carlito
ist natürlich die Sprache.
Einmal pro Woche besucht er
den Deutschunterricht in Altdorf.
Als er hierher kam, sprach er,
wie gesagt, noch kein Wort.
Und wenn das Gegenüber stimmt,
man sieht es gleich,
lernt es sich leicht.
Wie ist dein Name?
- Mein Name ist Denja.
Denja, qué bonito.
Okay.
Wie ist dein Vorname?
Ich heisse Carlos.
Zivilstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet?
- Ja.
Das ist schlecht für mich.
- Nein, sicher nicht.
Kurz darauf wird Carlito
in die Feuerwehr Flüelen aufgenommen.
Das sollte nun auch die letzten
Zweifler an seinem Schweizertum
zum Schweigen bringen.
Und, wie sehe ich aus?
Den Helm kann man hinten noch
einstellen, je nach Kopfgrösse.
Spürst du das?- Ja.
- Ist es besser?- Ja.
Okay.
* Lockere Musik *
Nach anderthalb Jahren
erstmals wieder zurück
in der Dominikanischen Republik.
Zusammen mit seiner Tante Lisbeth
und ihrem Mann Sepp
zu Besuch beim Vater
und bei den Brüdern.
Firabig-Karis Leben hat sich
äusserlich nicht gross verändert.
Doch vieles läuft nicht so,
wie er es sich erträumt hatte.
Geld wird immer mehr zur Mangelware.
Einfach gesagt:
Kari ist nun wirklich am Verarmen.
Ich habe immer weniger Arbeit.
Warum?
- Weil wir zu siebt schweissen.
Vorher war ich der einzige.
Hier im Dorf?
- Ja.
Jetzt schweissen wir zu siebt.
Jetzt hat sich die Arbeit verteilt.
Kaffee habe ich auch nur noch
etwa einen Drittel.
Weil ...
Ich habe nicht mehr erneuert
und die Pflanzen gehen langsam aus.
Ich habe noch etwa einen Drittel
des Kaffees, den ich anpflanzte.
Und jetzt kommen langsam ...
... finanzielle Probleme.
Versteckt unter Bananenstauden
hat Kari seine improvisierte
Schnapsbrennerei aufgebaut.
Hier brennt er verschiedene Sorten
exotischer Schnäpse -
schwarz natürlich.
Zuerst ...
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Da sind Bananen drin.
Die Schnäpse haben 62 % Alkohol
und schmecken am besten
als Kafi-Schnaps mit Tropen-Touch.
Es ist eine Frage der Zeit.
Daraus entsteht Bananenschnaps?
- Ja.
Das ist ein Waschkessel
aus der Schweiz.
Darin wurden früher
Leintücher gewaschen.
Den hast du mitgenommen?
- Ja, im Container.
Aus dem Waschkessel
ist eine funktionstüchtige
Busch-Destillerie geworden.
Der Bogen musste angelötet werden.
Und diesen hier.
Carlito ist für seine Brüder
so etwas wie ein Vorbild.
Er hat sich einen Computer
angeschafft und zeigt ihnen Bilder
aus der fernen Heimat Schweiz.
Er ist ihr Wegbereiter
in die bessere Zukunft.
Denn auch Sämi, Freddy und Pepe
träumen davon, dorthin zu ziehen,
wo Milch und Honig fliessen,
also in die Schweiz.
Lieber heute als morgen.
* Spanische Wortfetzen *
**
Kari macht mit seinen Buben
den ganzen Haushalt.
Denn seine Ehefrau Marina
ist wieder einmal weg.
Diesmal ist sie in Spanien,
wo sie als Putzfrau arbeitet,
um das Einkommen der Familie
aufzubessern.
Eine Zeitlang war sie in Miami, denn,
wir wollen es nicht verschweigen,
auch das Eheglück der Feierabends
ist nicht mehr so wie einst im Mai.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Mit dem selbst gebackenen Brot,
Bananenschnaps
und Käse aus der Schweiz,
fühlt man sich ein bisschen
wie vor Alpöhis Hütte.
Eine Idylle auf Zeit.
Die Frau ist auswärts.
Und auch die Kinder
wollen so bald wie möglich weg.
Was machst du, wenn alle vier Buben
in die Schweiz gehen?
Wieder ein Junggeselleben führen -
wie früher.
* Lachen *
Sonst hatte Kari
bei solchen Gelegenheiten
gern das Lied "Auf meiner Ranch
bin ich König" gesungen.
Doch heute stand ihm der Sinn
nach etwas Traurigem.
# I bi dr Schacher Seppeli,
im ganze Land bekannt.
# Bi friehner
s flöttischt Bürschtli gsi
# Jetzt bin i ä Vagant.
# Bi zfriede wenn i zNacht im Stroh,
# am Tag mis Schnäpsli ha.
# Und wenn dr Herrgott
Gsundheit schänkt,
# s isch alls was s brucht, ja ja.
# Wie gleitig gaht die Ziit verbii.
# Es Jährli und no eis.
# Es dunkt eim s sött ned mögli sii,
# bald bin i scho ä Greis.
# Und chumi denn vor d Himmelstüür,
# staht breit dr Petrus da.
# Er rüeft mer zue:
"Hei, sali Sepp!"
# "Bisch du nun äu scho da?"
* Originalversion von Ruedi Rymann *
# ... im ganze Land bekannt.
Am späteren Abend ging es Kari
ganz und gar nicht mehr gut.
Er musste in das fast 3 Std.
entfernte Spital gebracht werden.
Es wurde ihm schlecht
auf den holprigen Strassen.
Er konnte kaum mehr atmen.
Alles tat ihm weh.
Ein Wiedersehen im Notfall.
Presión ...
Sie machten ein Röntgenbild
von meiner Lunge: schwarz.
Bist du erschrocken?
Er hat nicht mehr ...
Alles deutet darauf hin, dass Kari
einen kleineren Herzinfarkt hatte.
Immer ruckartig.
Es drückte auf meiner Brust
und ich atmete wie ein Pferd.
So atmete ich.
Dazu dieser Druck auf der Brust.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Ich erschrak und dachte,
es gehe zu Ende mit mir.
Er sagt,
ihr könnt ihn täglich besuchen.
Pero tu puedes ir con ellos.
Ellos están aquí.
Creo que no duro mucho aquí.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Niemand hätte es gedacht:
Nach einem Tag im Spital
hatte Kari abends um halb elf
einen zweiten Herzinfarkt,
der sofort tödlich war.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Das halbe Dorf nahm Anteil
an seinem Schicksal.
25 Jahre sind wir nun
Nachbarn gewesen.
Aber ich kann nichts Schlechtes
über ihn sagen. Nur Gutes. Nur das.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Es ist so seltsam, auf die Farm
zu kommen und er ist nicht da.
Jetzt fehlt einfach jemand.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Es geht wohl allen so.
Die Farm war ein Teil von ihm.
Ja.
Ich merkte auch,
wie die Leute ihn hier mochten.
Sie trauerten alle.
Er nahm alle Menschen so,
wie sie waren.
So ...
Deshalb mochten sie ihn auch.
Er kritisierte nie Leute.
Er war einfach ein Feiner.
Glaubst du,
dass er hier glücklich war?
Auf eine Art sicher.
Er sagte es zumindest.
Er sang:
"Auf meiner Ranch bin ich König."
Er hatte immer wieder
ein Lied auf den Lippen.
Er war ein Zufriedener.
Auch wenn er nicht viel hatte.
Das wäre die Anmeldung
für seine Altersrente.
Ihr wolltet ihn für die AHV anmelden?
Ja, ab nächstem Jahr
hätte er die AHV erhalten.
War das ein Traum von ihm,
dass er dann ...
Er sprach nur davon.
Dann hätte er ausgesorgt.
Dann könne er hier leben.
Jetzt ist es anders gekommen.
Aus der Traum.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Carlos?
- Ja?
Wie war es ohne den Vater?
Es war eine schwierige Nacht.
Aha.
Was heisst schwierig?
Vor dem Schlafen
hat er immer mit uns gesprochen.
Er hat Witze gemacht.
In dieser Nacht nicht.
Das war für uns sehr seltsam.
Schlafen und ...
Wenn wir ...
Vater ist nicht mehr hier.
War ganz schwierig.
Hast du nun die Rolle des Vaters
eingenommen?
Ja.
Ich will das so.
Ich will zu meinen Brüdern schauen.
Was ist, wenn du
wieder in die Schweiz gehst?
Ja, ich komme ...
Ich komme immer im Dezember.
Jedes Jahr.
Ich schaue, wie ich das
mit den Brüdern mache.
Bevor ich gehe,
muss alles schön organisiert sein.
In einem Vorort von Barcelona
treffe ich Marina wieder.
Die Witwe von Kari
arbeitet hier als Hausangestellte.
Weil sie kein Flugticket
und kein Geld hatte,
konnte sie auch nicht zurückfliegen,
als ihr Mann starb.
Wie war das, als du hörtest,
dass er gestorben ist?
Es war sehr hart.
Ein harter Schlag.
Ich hätte nie so etwas gedacht.
Ich dachte:
Wenn ich dorthin zurückkehre,
werde ich ihn antreffen. Wie immer.
Nein, nie hätte ich gedacht, dass
mich ein solches Schicksal trifft.
Über seinen Tod hinaus
hat Kari für die Seinen gesorgt.
Weil sein Bruder in der Schweiz
immer brav die AHV einbezahlt hatte,
wird Marina eine schweizerische
Witwenrente bekommen -
und die Kinder eine Waisenrente,
so lange sie in Ausbildung sind.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
So endet die Geschichte
vom Schnapsbrenner Kari so,
wie alle Geschichten von Menschen
irgendwann enden.
Und sie setzt sich gleichzeitig fort,
wie sich alle Geschichten
von Menschen fortsetzen:
durch die Kinder und Kindeskinder
nämlich,
die noch lange
von Kari erzählen werden,
der aus dem fernen Lande
ausgerechnet hierherkam,
wo doch alle anderen
nichts wie weg wollen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
* Lockere Musik *
Jetzt will Carlos
die Geschichte der Familie Feierabend
in Rancho Arriba weiterschreiben.
Seinen Neuanfang finanziert er sich
mit Pensionskassengeld
aus der Schweiz.
Aber wenn er wirklich
hier leben will, muss er Wege suchen,
um nicht nur Geld zu brauchen,
sondern auch zu verdienen.
Hier möchte ich ein Café eröffnen.
Ein Café im Freien.
So einfach.
Einfach gemacht: alles wegschneiden,
Rasen säen,
einen schönen Platz machen.
Das Haus ist in der Nähe.
Mal schauen.
Es braucht Zeit, viel Zeit.
Daneben möchte er
als Handwerker arbeiten -
und einfach wieder glücklich sein,
so wie früher.
* Er ächzt.
Als Kind hatten wir ...
Wir waren reich.
Nicht mit Geld, aber anderen Sachen.
Wir hatten so viele Früchte.
Wir hatten so viel zum Spielen -
auch ohne Spielzeug.
Wir waren immer im Wald.
Es war eine schöne Kindheit,
das muss ich schon sagen.
Sehr schön.
Die ganze Freiheit auf der Farm.
Dazu die vielen Früchte.
Es ist sicher schön,
aber nicht mehr dasselbe wie früher.
Aber sicher schön für ein Kind.
Für andere Sachen ist es
in der Schweiz sicher besser.
Sicherheit z.B., die Schule.
Wenn ein Kind etwas lernen will,
ist es sicher besser in der Schweiz.
Das Leben hier
ist etwas landwirtschaftlicher.
Das ist auch schön.
Mir gefällt das Leben so.
Aber nicht alle Kinder wollen das.
Und auch nicht alle Frauen.
Soll ich dir eine Kokosnuss schälen?
- Nein, ich habe keine Lust.
Gar nicht?
- Nein, später vielleicht.
Du kannst dich zurücklehnen.
Obwohl Carlos sie rührend umsorgt
und ihr jeden Wunsch von den Augen
abzulesen versucht,
ist Samira bedrückt.
Denn sie vermisst ihre Mutter
und ihre Schwestern.
Möchtest du eine Frucht? Ich bringe
dir etwas, wenn du willst.
Nein, im Moment passt es.
Samira hat Heimweh,
aber wieder mal keinen Empfang.
Jetzt hatte ich anderthalb Tage
keinen Kontakt mit meiner Familie.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass sie sich auch Sorgen machen.
Ich mir auch, weil ich nicht weiss,
was bei ihnen läuft.
Und, ja ...
Es ist schon nicht so einfach -
zumindest im Moment.
Es ist einfach eine Unruhe da.
Ich bin heute auch etwas ...
Meine Gedanken sind immer bei ihnen.
Gestern habe ich sie
weder gesehen noch gehört
Man macht sich einfach immer Sorgen.
Ständig eigentlich.
Man vermisst sie noch mehr.
Daneben macht ihr auch zu schaffen,
dass man hier nie für sich sein kann.
Carlos hat dauernd Besuch.
Das soll er ändern.
Ihre Türen sollen öfter zu bleiben.
Wenn wir das machen,
verlieren wir viele Freunde.
Wenn wir alles zumachen
und nur Zeit für uns haben,
dann heisst es,
wir hätten kein Interesse.
Dann kommt morgen niemand mehr
und übermorgen auch nicht.
Und später kommt gar keiner mehr.
Das ist die hiesige Kultur.
Die Türen sind offen,
bis zuhinterst.
Du kannst reinkommen und rufen,
ob jemand da ist.
Wenn man am Essen ist,
kann der Gast gleich mitessen.
Ein Lichtblick für Samira:
Sie hat wieder Empfang.
Hallo.
- (Samira) Hoi.
(Beide) Wie geht's?
(Samira) Gut, dir?
Mir auch, danke.
Weisst du schon, wann du nach Hause
kommst? Hast du etwas gebucht?
Noch nicht. Ich habe mich
gestern mal umgeschaut.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich ...
... am 24. oder 25.,
an einem Freitag oder Samstag ...
Wir wissen noch nicht,
wie er mich an den Flughafen bringt,
da wir kein Auto haben.
Ihr habt noch ein paar Tage Zeit.
- Ja, ja.
In den nächsten Tagen
werde ich es machen.
Wir freuen uns.
Ja.
Ich lasse alle lieb grüssen.
Das richte ich aus.
Umarm sie fest von mir.
Das mache ich.
Ich nehme dich ganz fest in den Arm.
- Ich dich auch.
Bis bald wieder.
Bis bald.
Passt auf euch auf.
- (Samira) Ihr auf euch auch.
Macht's gut. Tschüss.
Ich habe dich fest lieb.
Ich dich auch. Tschüss.
Samiras Zeit in Rancho Arriba
geht nach gut fünf Wochen zu Ende.
Sie fliegt bald zurück in die Schweiz
und muss sich entscheiden,
wo sie künftig leben will,
in der Karibik oder in Flüelen -
und wie es mit ihr
und Carlos weitergeht.
Ich stelle mir viel mit ihm vor,
also wirklich die Zukunft.
Da es für ihn in der Schweiz
nicht möglich ist,
muss ich mich für etwas entscheiden.
Es wird so oder so schwer.
Entweder meine Familie zurücklassen
oder ihn hier zurücklassen.
Es wird nicht einfach.
Wenn sie sich entscheidet,
wieder zurückzugehen ...
... dann wird es leider so sein und
ich muss allein hier weitermachen.
Wenn sie in die Schweiz geht
und wieder zu mir zurückkommt,
dann wäre das sehr schön
und es würde mich sehr freuen.
Kurz gesagt:
Es geht jetzt um die Frage,
ob diese Liebe eine Zukunft hat.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nach dem Tod des Vaters schien klar,
dass die Zukunft der Feierabends
in der Schweiz liegt.
Darum holt Carlos bald
seinen jüngsten Bruder Sämi zu sich.
Er soll in der Schweiz
zur Schule gehen
und später
eine Berufslehre machen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli"
Hallo, Sämi.
Bienvenido.
Gut?
* Stimmengewirr *
So nehmen die Kinder den gleichen Weg
wie der Vater - nur umgekehrt.
Und so setzt sich das Prinzip
von Leben und Sterben,
von Kommen und Gehen durch.
Noch lange nicht Feierabend.
Ein Jahr später
stehen die Feierabend-Brüder
wieder am Flughafen.
Sämi und Carlito warten zusammen
mit Onkel Sepp auf die Mutter:
auf Marina.
Für Sämi geht diese lange Zeit
der Einsamkeit zu Ende.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Mit Marina kommt Freddy,
der dritte der Söhne von Kari.
Jetzt ist nur noch Pepe
in der Karibik.
Doch auch er wird bald hier sein.
Das liegt, wie wir gemerkt haben,
in der Logik dieser Geschichte.
Wie geht es dir, Marina?
Ich bin so glücklich.
Jetzt habe ich schon mal
ein Trio hier.
Marina ist fest entschlossen, in der
Schweiz ein neues Leben zu beginnen.
In Witterschwanden im Schächental,
dort, wo im Winter drei Monate lang
die Sonne nie scheint,
hat Carlito für die ganze Familie
eine günstige Wohnung gemietet -
weitab vom Schuss.
Salü. Buenos días.
Puedes ver un poco el apartamento.
- Claro, ya.
Que hay aquí.
Fünfeinhalb Zimmer,
noch etwas provisorisch eingerichtet,
aber immerhin:
ein neues Zuhause für die Familie.
Y a la izquierda hay una habitación,
dónde veemos un poco la tele.
Hier würden sie fernsehen,
sagt Marina,
obwohl sie die "Tagesschau"
noch nicht wirklich versteht.
Marina ist stolz und zeigt mir
das Zimmer von Carlito,
das sie ausgesprochen
romantisch findet.
A la derecha tenemos
la habitación de Carlos.
Tiene ventanas muy románticas.
* Marina lacht. *
Nein, einen solchen Kühlschrank hatte
Marina, die leidenschaftliche Köchin,
noch nie.
Es muy differente a la situación
en Santo Domingo?
- Sí. Muy differente.
Die Einrichtung bringt die Familie an
den Rand ihrer finanziellen Kräfte.
Ihre Einkünfte aus Witwenrente
und Carlitos Lohn
liegen um 4'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Alles ist teuer in der Schweiz.
Und die Jungen
sind den elektronischen Verführungen
ziemlich ausgeliefert.
Mit Schweizer Franken zu rechnen,
das müssen sie erst noch lernen.
Suchst du eigentlich Arbeit hier?
Ja, ich will etwas arbeiten.
Ich frage nicht, was mir gefällt,
ich suche irgendetwas.
Ich möchte nicht reich werden
oder so etwas.
Ich möchte nur etwas
zum Leben haben.
Und ich möchte alles, was möglich
ist für mich - und noch etwas mehr,
damit ich für die anderen
meiner Familie sorgen kann.
Das ist Freddys Zimmer.
Hier haben wir
alle Trophäen von Kari.
Seine Medaillen, Kristalle usw.
Das ist ja wie ein Museum.
Ja, genau.
Und hier ist noch seine Uhr.
Die läuft immer noch.
# Und am Abend träumen sie
von Santo Domingo.
Kari ist in der Wohnung omnipräsent.
Die Bilder an der Wand machen
die Familiengeschichte zur Legende.
Doch wie wir wissen, gab es in dieser
Ehe nicht nur eitel Sonnenschein.
Wie es denn so gewesen sei mit Kari,
wollen wir von Marina wissen.
Auf der einen Seite war es gut,
aber auf der anderen ...
Also, nein ...
Eines muss ich sagen:
Er war fleissig.
Und er war gut
zu den Kindern. Da fehlte nichts.
Aber es fehlte etwas anderes.
Mir fehlte etwas. Ich kam zu kurz.
Und ich bin doch das Wichtigste.
Aber lassen wir das vor der Kamera.
In Altdorf, im Hotel Höfli,
hat Marina dank der guten Beziehungen
ihrer Schweizer Verwandten
eine Stelle als Putzfrau gefunden.
Es zeigt sich allerdings bald,
dass Marina nicht glücklich wird
in der Schweiz.
Ihr fehlt hier die soziale Wärme
der Karibik.
Und darum zieht es sie schon
nach zwei Jahren wieder zurück.
Auch Carlos plagt die Sehnsucht
nach seiner alten Heimat -
mal mehr, mal weniger.
Und er träumt immer noch
denselben Traum,
den Traum vom kleinen Haus
in Rancho Arriba.
Da gäbe es einen Garten.
Oben der ...
Da wäre die Küche.
Waschküche, Toilette
und noch ein Zimmer.
Dann kommt die Decke.
Das wäre diese hier.
Wo willst du dieses Haus bauen?
Das wäre ein Traumhaus.
Wo?
- Auf unserer Farm in Santo Domingo.
Ach so.
Das wäre eigentlich ...
Ungefähr so.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Ich muss z.B.
noch die Fenster montieren,
aus Plexiglas.
Und dort willst du leben?
Ja, in meiner Zukunft.
Ich will zurückgehen.
Inzwischen ist Carlos seinem Traum
einen grossen Schritt nähergekommen.
Auf der Feierabend-Ranch gibt es
wohl schon bald einen neuen König.
* Schlagerlied: "Auf meiner Ranch
bin ich König" von Peter Hinnen *
# Auf meiner Ranch bin ich König.
# Die laute Welt lockt mich wenig.
Er hat einen künstlichen Teich
angelegt.
Und einen Unterstand
für Fahrzeuge gebaut.
Ausserdem einen kleinen Schuppen
für die Werkzeuge.
Ein paar Monate nach seiner Ankunft
in Rancho Arriba
arbeitet er gerade am Dach
seines Traumhauses.
Ich habe jeden Tag gearbeitet,
ausser ...
... an drei Sonntagen nicht,
einschliesslich heute.
Sonst habe ich jeden Tag gearbeitet,
immer etwas gemacht.
Mit dem Holz
und es gibt einfach viel zu tun.
Es ist noch nicht fertig,
es fehlt noch sehr viel.
Das wird das Wohnzimmer.
Das wird ein Zimmer.
Oben wird es zwei Zimmer geben.
Ein Giebelzimmer,
wie man es in der Schweiz nennt.
Und ...
Da vorne gibt es ein Fenster.
Da hinten auch.
Und es gibt einen anderen Boden.
Es kommt auch noch etwas Beton
drauf, damit es stabiler wird.
Eine wahnsinnig schöne Aussicht
hat man nicht,
aber sie reicht.
Gar nicht so schlecht, ziemlich gut.
Schweizer Qualitätsarbeit.
Mit einem anderen Holz
wäre es sicher viel besser geworden.
Mit dem Hartholz
ist es nicht so einfach.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Mit Fichte oder Tanne - wie in
der Schweiz - wäre es viel schöner.
Ein Bekannter drehte Carlos
allerdings Eukalyptusholz an
und versprach,
ihm damit ein Dach zu bauen.
Wenn die Sonne draufscheint,
biegt sich das Holz.
Man bringt es schon gerade,
aber ...
Es wäre besser,
wenn es nicht so wäre.
Als ihm Carlos
das Holz abgekauft hatte,
machte sich der Bekannte
aus dem Staub.
Nun muss Carlos sein Dach
selbst bauen.
Jetzt muss ich halt improvisieren
und ich muss vieles von Hand machen.
Es braucht sehr viel Zeit.
Ich kriege das schon hin.
Am Schluss sieht das wieder gut aus.
In der Schweiz hat Carlos
eine Anlehre als Schreiner gemacht
und immer auf dem Beruf gearbeitet.
Darum liegt ihm der Umgang mit Holz.
Er hat sich sogar
ein kleines Baumhaus gebaut.
Ein liebevoll eingerichteter
Rückzugsort für zwei,
wo er nun allerdings allein ist.
Denn Samira
ist schon lange nicht mehr da.
Sie ist zurück in der Schweiz.
Zu allem wollte ich
Samiras Meinung wissen,
was sie dachte.
Jetzt mache ich das Haus
und sie ist nicht da.
Ich kann sie nicht
um ihre Meinung fragen.
Ich würde das gern machen, ich würde
gern mit ihr kommunizieren.
Sie fand das auch gut.
Und jetzt ist sie nicht da,
ich vermisse sie.
Jeden Tag, jeden Moment.
War das Abschiednehmen
ein schwieriger Moment?
Ja.
Sehr schwierig. Es war schon hart.
Wir waren die ganze Zeit zusammen.
Wir waren überall
mit dem Motorrad zusammen unterwegs.
Einkaufen, jemanden besuchen.
Wir haben alles zusammengemacht.
Und jetzt ist sie nicht mehr da.
Es ist immer noch seltsam,
allein mit dem Motorrad zu fahren.
Sie hat sich immer
an mir festgehalten.
Ja ...
So ist es.
Geblieben sind ihm
ihre Liebesbotschaften -
immerhin.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Wir treffen Samira wieder in Flüelen.
Sie arbeitet
in einer Papeterie in Stans.
Und sie wohnt an einem neuen Ort:
Sie ist bei ihrer Mutter eingezogen.
Sonst scheint alles
beim Alten zu sein.
Jedenfalls fast alles.
Einiges wirft Fragen auf.
Es ist so, dass ich schwanger bin.
Ich bin im fünften Monat.
Carlos und ich erwarten ein Baby.
Nun liest sie fleissig Bücher,
um sich auf die Ankunft
ihres ersten Kindes vorzubereiten.
Vom Kind wusste sie, ehrlich gesagt,
schon in der Karibik,
teilte das süsse Geheimnis
aber nur mit ihrer Mutter und Carlos.
Er war dabei, als ich
den Schwangerschaftstest machte.
Er wartete draussen
auf das Ergebnis.
Ich sagte dann,
es sei noch nicht ganz eindeutig
aber wie es aussehe,
sei ich schwanger.
Er freute sich mega, nahm mich
sogleich in die Arme, hob mich hoch
und wirbelte mich herum.
Er war wirklich sehr süss
und überrascht.
Er hat sich wirklich sehr gefreut.
Schatzi.
- Hoi, Schatzi.
Geht es dir gut?
Ja, und dir?
- Mir auch, danke.
Wie geht's dem Bauch, Schätzeli?
- Ganz gut.
Alles gut.- Ja?
- Ja.
Schön. Schatz, du fehlst mir.
Du mir auch.
Wie geht es deinem Mami und Manolin?
Beiden gut.
Sie haben viele Bohnen geerntet.
Dann war es eine gute Ernte?
Ja.
Ich freue mich,
ich kann es kaum abwarten.
Ja.
Bis später. Ich liebe dich.
- Ich dich auch.
Tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.
Ich vermisse ihn jeden Tag sehr.
Es gibt Tage,
an denen es sehr schlimm ist.
Dann bin ich froh,
wenn mein Mami hier ist
oder wenn meine Familie um mich ist.
Dann geht es wieder besser.
Aber es gibt schon Momente,
in denen man seine Nähe
brauchen würde.
Z.B. gerade jetzt
während der Schwangerschaft.
Es gab auch Situationen,
in denen er mich
hätte beruhigen können
oder wo er mich
in den Arm genommen hätte.
Das fehlt halt schon.
Umso enger ist nun die Beziehung
zu ihrer Mutter Angela,
mit der sie Kataloge
für Baby-Accessoires studiert.
Nach ihrer Rückkehr sei schnell
klar gewesen, dass sie die Wohnung,
die sie mit Carlos bewohnt hatte,
aufgeben wollte.
Das ist auch süss.
(Mutter) Ja, sehr.
Es war dann halt schon ...
... sehr einsam, allein.
Deshalb habe ich mich
bald einmal dazu entschieden,
dass ich aus der Wohnung
ausziehen musste.
Ich war natürlich superhappy,
dass ich zu meinem Mami ziehen
und bleiben durfte.
Es ist so ein Glück,
dass ich das erleben darf.
Dass sie wieder hier ist
und wir es gut zusammen haben.
Es ist einfach schön.
Offen ist indes, was dieses Baby für
Samiras Auswanderungspläne bedeutet.
Geht sie? Oder bleibt sie?
Ich habe mich entschieden,
das Baby in der Schweiz zu bekommen
und auch ziemlich grosszuziehen.
Ich machte in der Dominikanischen
Republik eine Erfahrung
mit einer Frauenärztin ...
Ich habe
das dortige Gesundheitssystem
etwas näher kennengelernt.
Mir hat das Ganze Angst gemacht.
Deshalb musste ich sagen,
dass ich mich
in der Schweiz wohler fühle,
um ein Kind sicher zu gebären.
Und sicher auch,
bis es etwas grösser ist,
bis ich weiss,
dass wirklich alles gut wird.
Carlos baut weiter
jeden Tag am Haus,
in dem er eigentlich
mit Samira leben wollte.
Der Traum vom gemeinsamen Glück
in der Karibik
ist nun allerdings geplatzt.
Es war schon etwas ...
... ein Schock.
Sie sagte, sie wolle mich begleiten
und hier eine Zukunft aufzubauen.
Ich habe das ernst genommen,
deshalb habe ich so viel gemacht.
Ich wollte für uns
ein Zuhause machen.
Ich habe das so ernst genommen.
Ich wollte das Beste machen,
dass es ihr gefällt,
dass es für sie bequem ist,
dass sie sagen kann:
"Wir haben ein schönes Zuhause."
"Wir haben alles, was wir brauchen."
Warst du am Anfang traurig?
Ja, nein. Es geht.
Ich war einfach etwas schockiert.
Ich habe ein bisschen erwartet,
dass sie vielleicht zurückgeht,
aber dass sie wieder kommt, wieder
geht, wieder kommt und dann bleibt.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass sie wiederkommt, um zu bleiben.
Ich denke, sie kommt, um Ferien
zu machen - für mich okay.
Es sollte der Anfang eines neuen
Lebens in der alten Heimat werden.
Dafür hat Carlos alles aufgegeben
in der Schweiz.
Wenn sie nicht hier sein kann,
muss ich in die Schweiz gehen.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt,
ob ich soll oder nicht.
Ich muss sagen ...
Wäre sie nicht schwanger,
hätte ich mir noch mehr überlegt,
ob ich zurückgehen soll.
Aber jetzt sind wir eine Familie
und ich komme sehr gern zurück.
Allein hierzubleiben
kam für dich nicht infrage?
Samira und das Kind in der Schweiz
und du hier?
Nein, das möchte ich nicht.
Auf keinen Fall.
Entweder sind wir zusammen hier
oder dort.
Das ist ganz klar.
* Sanfte,
vereinzelte Gitarrenklänge *
Wenn er mit dem Schicksal hadert,
dann zieht es Carlos
zum Grab seines Vaters.
Dorthin, wo Firabig-Kari
seine letzte Ruhe gefunden hat.
Zu seinem Vater,
dem Schnapsbrenner aus Rotkreuz,
der in der Karibik
all sein Geld verloren
und dafür die Liebe gefunden hat.
Zu dem Mann aus der Schweiz,
den hier alle mochten -
und der doch vielen
irgendwie ein Rätsel blieb.
Das fing schon
bei seinem Nachnamen an.
Sie haben vergessen,
ein D zu schreiben.
Deshalb muss ich es immer wieder
mit dem Filzstift nachmalen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik:
"Dr Schacher Seppli" *
Ich denke, das Leben gab ihm
etwas anderes, als er wollte.
Am Schluss ist er aber
damit zurechtgekommen.
Wiederholt sich das bei dir?
Ja, vielleicht.
Vielleicht schon, ja.
Ich habe einfach keine Angst.
Ich nehme die Sache so,
wie sie kommt.
Ich mache das Beste.
Ich weiss, ich kann glücklich sein -
egal wo.
Das ist so.
Die Geschichte der Familie Feierabend
ist noch lange nicht zu Ende erzählt.
Denn ihre Suche nach dem Glück
geht weiter -
irgendwo zwischen hier und dort.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2021